which will make that distinction for us
between what Noah's had goods and
services which seemed to be a compelling
space for impact investing and and and
other spaces like social justice I would
actually not necessarily agree well no I
think that there is space for
traditional ground-based philanthropy
but the focus should be more on
catalytic philanthropy and
accountability in reaching you know
really creating of change rather than
you know spending in a writing checks
for example you know if you want to
support children who are orphans you
know very difficult to create a business
enterprise so charitable dollars will go
to reach this goal an important
dimension of charitable dollars is also
at the start of impact investing with
when a cattle eating new model is being
tested it may not provide the returns so
there is a time in the development of
social enterprise where they can only
survive on charitable dollars an example
would be barefoot power which provides
solar kids for the remote villages in
Africa they sell them at $12 which
represents three months of you know
kerosene sales and they last five years
so after three months the household
starts to save money they have 12 12
times the luminosity they can start
micro telephone charging businesses huge
financial and huge social benefits but
they had to start with philanthropy
because at the beginning they didn't
have the distribution systems their
product was too expensive it wasn't
commercially viable now they entered the
space where they can scale and attract
semi commercial capital and then
hopefully they will go further by
continuing research and development
expanding creating economies of scale
and they can attract purely commercial
so I think they're they're still you
know
a you know a space and place for
philanthropy